now one of the things I think that
attracted you to this film Robert is
your home life animals is it a farm you
have we yeah we wound up inheriting what
was an old dog and horse rescue oh I see
up there in Malibu way and then there
was all these empty stables and I I
can't stand negative space plus I'm a
softie at heart and there's a lot of
rescue
so these old rescues largely you've got
some llamas yeah where's Madre and all
that is fuzzy on the left they were
rescued from I needed sweaters I think
she's gone too short myself she's the
Alpha don't mess up her and then you've
got these lovely cows we do those our
Oreo cows I saw some in Richmond and
then they said they had them up in Santa
Barbara so give us a couple Belted
Galloway's I believe they're cold thank
you you're welcome
[Applause]
felt-tip Galloway's oreo cows is cute is
better
that's an Oreo cow but then you've got
some very ordinary things you've got
some chickens knocking around yes that's
a bird up front you don't know the names
on it then
now goats I feel are hard to keep these
years that looks like that's a trigger
and memo they are pygmy goats and there
are also brother lovers oh very modern
it's perfect yeah not when they're
active okay this is this trigger mmm oh
this one oh my god that is our newest
one and and his sweet name is flash and
that's a real he's a real rescue he
looks like he's possessed by the devil
you have one of the most relaxed cats
I've ever seen that's Montgomery named
after your great general that's amazing
he's sort of more of an ointment
yes he's heavily sedated there
[Music]
you